retail experts let's move on predict
this year will end with nearly 7,000
store closings across the u.s. but one
retailer is joined joining the growing
list of online companies opening
brick-and-mortar stores ever Lane known
for selling ethically made clothing and
accessories at affordable prices just
opened its first physical store in New
York City the move marks a huge
departure from whatever land co-founder
and CEO Michael praise Minh told The New
York Times in 2012 back then he said we
are going to shut the company down
before we go to physical retail I am
quoting you in your own words mark right
here fast company estimates every Lane
earned one hundred million dollars in
revenue last year Michael praising is at
the table so you kind of chuckled when
you heard yourself
few years back so why were you wrong
let's talk about that for just a second
let's talk about it so adamant about it
but I heard on The Oprah Winfrey Show
years ago you have the right to change
your mind no one absolutely we believe
that when we started six years ago we
thought we could do this online only
what we found is customers like to touch
things before they buy them you know
especially products when it's cashmere
when it's nice quality and then moreover
everlean is really about that ethical
part of the brand and we want to help
bring that mission to life so we've
started to tell the stories of our
product we wanted to build a space where
we can do that and so we decided retail
is that Avenue for us was it a hard
decision to make after you were so
adamant about I'm not ever was it I
think the hardest part was the number of
people telling me that I made that coke
and rubbing it a bit in my face but you
know what it's okay
so was it that you were facing declining
sales or you just weren't growing no
we've been growing we've been doubling
every year for the past three years it's
really an opportunity for us to bring
the mission to life we you know the
ethics the transparency we tell you the
cost of everything we make
and then what you're paying so you can
see that markup and we tell you the
stories of our factories and we want
people to have a space where we can
actually tell those stories in real life
not just online but as you know time is
money for consumers these days and it's
really hard to get people into a store
what is it that you're doing that
entices people to come in I it was it
was a scene I never expected we had 75
people in line
the entire weekend for the store and I
think what they're looking for beyond
just retail is an experience they want
to come in they want to feel the brand
and they want to bring that to life and
traditional retail isn't doing that
right now
for people that don't know whatever Lane
is what do you sell if I go to your
store what are you wearing your your I
am right here tea button-downs we have
denim we just launched denim and it's
mostly actually for women we sell all
basics and the idea is to create the
best quality basics and offer them in a
transparent and ethical way you keep
saying that word transparent what do you
mean by that being true so imagine that
you know when you buy our cashmere you
know the factory where it came from you
know how many workers work there you
know that we've done all the right
audience and every product you can feel
comfortable buying from everything I
heard you're doable
I heard from reliable sources that
there's something on your store that you
can actually hear the making of a
t-shirt I have no idea what that means
so you can actually walk in and we've
recorded the 13 there's 13 sounds of a
t-shirt the different sewing the
different finishing the dyeing process
and you can put that on and here inside
of our Factory we actually even give if
you're in LA we give tours of our
factory so where most of your clothes
made so it depends every product is best
for that country so all of our shoes are
made in Italy we have cashmere that
comes out of inner mongolia we make
t-shirts in los angeles and there's a
lot now happening in vietnam so denim we
found one of the cleanest factories in
the world and it's made just outside Ho
Chi Minh City to go back to the
experience of actually being in the
store what's interesting that we are
seeing in more and more stores is the
socializing bringing people together
hosting events doing yoga classes
what-have-you so it's not about the
individual shopper as much sure about
the collective experience yeah we're not
doing yoga classes yet we don't have
yoga clothes but we're you know this
evening we're hosting an event where
people can come learn about the future
of retail ask questions and even ask me
why we made certain decisions so we're
gonna be doing events all throughout the
months and we believe that's a big part
of the future of retail and you started
this company when you were 25 I work
with kids like yourself how old are you
now I'm 32 32 so what did you see at 25
that you thought I want to do what I
grew up on the west coast and in the
West Coast there's this really open and
honest way of communication and the
internet was part of that the beatnik
movement we thought that we could do the
same thing to apparel and you said
affordable what's your definition of
affordable we've got denim at $68 we've
got button-downs at $50 we've got
so-call under $100 who's your target
consumer in our mind it's anyone who
wants to know where their product comes
from so we're seeing people 18 years old
and 65 years old come into the store
that's a big ol drain it is a big range
but it's Faceman we've said it's about a
state of mind you know it's about
wanting to know it's about wanting value
it's about wanting to get quality and
we're really trying to make quality
products that last and there's a real
shift in consumers nowadays you're right
about that congrats to you you and your
stuff right yeah yeah thank you very
much for coming to the table thank you